bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro live nous vous
faisons vivre l'hommage national rendu
aux invalides au sergent maxime blasco
52e militaire français décédé en
opération au sahel depuis le lancement
de l'opération barkan en 2013 le soldat
français a perdu la vie vendredi 24
septembre au mali lors d'une opération
contre les djihadistes maxime blasco
avait 34 ans la cérémonie d'hommage
national sera présidée par le président
de la république emmanuel macron et elle
se déroulera dans la cour d'honneur de
l'hôtel national des invalides à 16h30
d'ici une petite quinzaine de minutes
donc on suivra ça en direct avec nous un
peu plus tôt dans l'après midi le
cortège funéraire a franchi à 15h vous
le voyez sur ces images en différé le
pont alexandre iii à paris comme le veut
la tradition tous ceux qui le
souhaitaient auront ainsi pu vivre un
dernier hommage pu rendre un dernier
hommage au sergent maxime blasco vous le
voyez sur ces images ce cortège
funéraire dont qui reliait le pont
alexandre iii aux invalides escortés par
des motards et ce chemin ce pont sur les
côtés duquel étaient massés
des militaires et puis une partie des
personnes comme vous et moi qui auront
souhaité rendre un dernier hommage aux
soldats maxime blasco demain jeudi un
autre hommage lui sera rendu à varces en
isère par ses frères d'armes du 7e
bataillon de chasseurs alpins pour
commenter avec nous cette cérémonie
henry veille est avec nous bonjour henry
veille bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes journaliste
et historien votre dernier ouvrage
résister à 20 ans l'engagement des
compagnons de la libération est édité
chez privat on en voit en ce moment la
couverture pour ceux que ça intéresse
n'hésitez pas il est disponible en
librairie
au réveil l'hommage de la nation un
soldat ne peut se dérouler qu aux
invalides ouais c'est la tradition
surtout depuis napoléon
la cour d'honneur qui s'appelait la cour
royale lorsqu'elle a été inaugurée en
1674 et ben est devenu un lieu majeur de
la construction de la mémoire nationale
on le voit sur ces images en diffuser
cette fois ci en direct depuis donc
cette cour d'honneur de l'hôtel des
invalides la garde républicaine qui est
là et puis quelques invités qui commença
à finir de s'installer dans cette cour
où se déroulera donc dans 15 minutes cet
hommage national on attend évidemment
l'arrivée de deux des manuels macron au
réveil pour pourquoi pourquoi cette cet
hôtel national des invalides comme lieu
de deux cérémonies comme du dommage
lorsqu'un soldat meurt au combat
pourquoi c'est à cet endroit là qu'on
fait là-bas tout simplement d'abord
parce que lorsque louis xiv a décidé par
décret en 1670 de l'ériger c'était pour
les militaires les militaires qui
souffrait et les militaires qui étaient
indigents et les militaires qui étaient
blessés donc il ya une tradition qui
s'est perpétuée et comme je le disais à
partir de napoléon c'est devenu un
endroit où on a célébré le les
militaires et puis c'est aussi le
carrefour ce fameux lien armée nation
dans les politiques souvent et évoque
dans le discours public et bien c'est
une réalité alors ça l'est encore plus
depuis la première guerre mondiale mais
vous notez aussi incertain glissement
parce que ces dernières années on y est
célébrée également les morts de novembre
2015 on a rendu un hommage à jean
d'ormesson simone veil on le voit sur
ces images diffusées en direct quelques
crânes des canons d'abord les canons
effectivement mais aussi des
personnalités politiques on voit
monsieur vers ans qui arrive en ce
moment dans la cour d'honneur des
invalides on a pu voir l'arrivée lionel
jospin installé déjà manuel valls
également alain juppé sont présents dans
cette cour d'honneur j'imagine que ce
sont les chasseurs alpins qu'on voit
l'image est tout à fait ça les chasseurs
alpins de la 27e brigade d'infanterie de
montagne dont faisait partie et dont
fait partie pardon le 7e régiment de
chasseurs dont
maxime est peut-être l'un des des cadres
si vous voulez nous si vous venez de
nous rejoindre en direct sur figaro live
et sur la chaîne figaro live youtube
nous allons vous faire vivre la
cérémonie d'hommage national qui sera
rendu au sergent maxime blasko un moment
de recueillement auquel vont assister la
famille de maxime blasco dont sa femme
alexandra et son fils de 8 ans et anne
se représente évidemment le chef de
l'état emmanuel macron mais aussi le
premier ministre jean castex la ministre
des armées florence parly et les
autorités militaires on le voit encore
sur ces images des personnalités
politiques sont d'ores et déjà arrivés
comme je vous le disais alain juppé
manuel valls lionel jospin sont d'ores
et déjà installés dans cette cour
d'honneur vous n'hésitez pas à nous
faire part de vos commentaires de vos
questions pendant ce direct et gelé
relaieraient à notre invité henri veille
journaliste et historien henry veille
c'est c'est le parcours exceptionnel du
soldat français qui a beaucoup été
évoquée ces derniers jours on a pu lire
beaucoup de choses à son sujet
extrêmement élogieux c'était quelqu'un
qui avait un parcours opérationnel
exceptionnel a notamment souligné le
colonel pascal yani porte parole des
armées quels étaient les faits d'armes
de maxime d'ascq au promu au rang de
sergent oui titre posthume à mais vous
savez il l'avait novembre de services un
c'est un grenoblois donc il s'est engagé
dans son propre département et en 9 ans
de service il avait quand même quatre
citations ce qui était exceptionnel et
le président de la république le 18 juin
au dernier lui avait remis la médaille
militaire à 34 ans c'est quand même
relativement exceptionnel alors on
évoque effectivement le j'entendais le
chef de corps ce matin de ce régiment
qui notait que il avait fait six séjours
dans cette bande sahélo-sahélienne c'est
à dire ou au mali et on évoque
évidemment
cette cet acte héroïque accompli en mai
2010 neuf où effectivement il avait été
engagé à bord d'une gazelle c'était un
tireur de précision et la gazelle
avaient été touchés par des rebelles là
l'hélicoptère était tombé s'était crashé
et bien que blessé il avait été éjecté
il est avait été blessé mais il était
parvenu à extraire alors que le feu
commençait à consumer l'appareil le
pilote et le copilote ce qui est quand
même un acte héroïque on voit ça dans
les romans on voit ça dans
un
certain nombre de films mais c'était la
réalité alors c'est vrai qu'on en parle
lui même et est également grièvement
blessé
absolument blessés mais ce qui n'avait
pas empêché et là ils accomplissaient
maxime blasco son sixième séjour c'est
un véritable héros nous dit i'm cas sur
le chat du figaro merci d'ailleurs de
participer en direct au tchad du figaro
n'hésitez pas à faire quand même qu'à
nous faire part de vos commentaires
votre émotion vos questions au sujet de
cet hommage national rendu à ce soldat
tué par un djihadiste au mali
[Musique]
très très intéressant puisque nous nos
journalistes nous là que nous
l'utilisons très très facilement qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un héros seulement et
effectivement je me souviens si vous le
permettez vous raconter l'anecdote je me
souviens de cette conversation que
j'avais eue avec comme compagnon de la
libération jean pierre vernant
professeur au collège de france
spécialiste de la grèce antique et le
héros pour lui c'était achille et
achille fils d'une déesse du neuf téthys
et d'un mortel avait été confronté à un
dilemme
fallait-il choisir de vivre longtemps et
ne pas s'engager militairement pour
vivre auprès des siens jusqu'à que la
mort vous céiste dans la force de l'âge
ou fallait-il combattre et mourir et
dans ce cas là la mort héroïque vous
gagnerez et la gloire impérissable
également c'est une question le mot
héros je pense je pense très sincèrement
est adapté à maxime blasco respect en
majuscules nous dit grégoire de ma le
vois de malavoi sur le chat du figaro
alors qu'on voyait arriver dans cette
cour d'honneur jean yves le drian en
arrière-plan manuel valls alain juppé on
a pu voir également jean-pierre raffarin
il ya quelques minutes
le fait d'armes particulièrement
héroïque que vous venez de raconter un
alors qu'on voit françois hollande
arrivé
c'est un
élément majeur dans la représentation
qu'on se fait du héros aujourd'hui et le
fait qu'il ait qualifié de l'es20 maxime
la sq on le voit les internautes aussi
qualifie cet homme de héros alors qu'on
ne le connaît pas oui mais c'est pas
qu'ils aient posé la question à tous les
militaires qui combattent la mort est
une hypothèse de travail quand vous
paraphé un contrat qui vous lie à
l'institution militaire vous savez que
peut-être un jour où vous pouvez laisser
votre sang pour la patrie la patrie
cette notion aujourd'hui qui n'a plus le
même sens qu auparavant justement par
exemple en 1940 je me souviens d'avoir
posé cette question de du héros êtes
vous un héros à des parachutistes qui en
2008 ont été victimes de l'embuscade
d'uzbin en afghanistan où dix
parachutistes du 8e rpima de castres ont
laissé la peau ainsi qu'un
légionnaires du 2ème rep mais tous m'ont
dit mais monsieur nous ne sommes pas des
ro nous avons simplement fait notre
travail et notre travail à propos de
travail et d'engagement cyril georges
jerusalemy nous préciser nous corrige
vous êtes là pour çà également quand on
parle parfois on fait des erreurs vous
nous préciser que ce n'est pas un régime
en mai un bataillon de chasseurs alpins
qu'on a pu voir à l'image et quelques
minutes vêtus de blanc vous êtes ancien
chasseur alpin vous même vous le
préciser et vous dites que en tant que
chasseur alpin vous tenez à cela ce qu
on précise que c'est un bataillon que
c'est un régiment mais pas un bataillon
merci à vous tout à fait raison vous
êtes en direct avec nous sur figaro live
et sur youtube pour assister à cette
cérémonie
rendu en hommage à maxime blasco ce
soldat tué le 24 septembre dernier au
mali lors d'une opération sur le terrain
tué par un jihadiste de nombreuses
personnalités politiques sont déjà
rassemblés
là c'est dans cette cour d'honneur des
invalides pour assister à cet hommage
national on attend l'arrivée du chef de
l'état emmanuel macron on parlait de ce
fait d'armes particulièrement héroïque à
mettre
au parcours du de maxime blasco et qui
lui a valu la reconnaissance des armées
d'être décoré de la croix de la valeur
militaire avec étoile de vermeil puis de
la médaille militaire d' emmanuel macron
c'est assez exceptionnel si on quatre
citations que je vaux qu'est tout à
l'heure c'était assez exceptionnel je
crois savoir la médaille militaire comme
caporal-chef après neuf ans de service
s'est relativement quoi absolument c'est
une très haute distinction pour un
militaire un sous-officier c'est sa
légion d'honneur donc il faut savoir
qu'à 34 ans être ainsi décoré reconnu
par la nation comme étant l'un des siens
et qui a combattu le brave mans c'est
effectivement une immense satisfaction
même si je crois savoir et beaucoup de
confrères de deux camarades parlent de
maxime blasco comme étant un homme
extrêmement discret extrêmement serein
mais également d'une humilité
déconcertante
on vous laisse regarder quelques
secondes ces images diffusées en direct
donc depuis la cour d'honneur des
invalides
on voit une partie
et colonnes si on peut appeler ça comme
ça qu'ils sont occupés par du public
il y a évidemment un certain nombre de
militaires l'officier général issu
effectivement les troupes de montagne et
donc on a pu voir tout à l'heure un
bataillon de chasseurs alpins les
chasseurs alpins dont était issue maxime
blasco qui est chasseur alpin de
chasseurs alpins en réveil qui sont-ils
et où sont basés on peut peut-être même
dire quelques mots de leur mission bah
écoute et ils ont été créés au 19e
siècle pour protéger les alpes et donc
les chasseurs alpins sont
du côté de grenoble ils sont à agapes
donc ils sont à à vars en ce qui
concerne le 7e bataillon de chasseurs
mais il ya également un régiment de la
légion étrangère qui est rattachée c'est
le 2e régiment étranger de génie qui lui
est basée dans le vaucluse à à saint
christol qui est qui est rattachée donc
des troupes qui se sentent toujours
vaillamment comporter la devise
d'ailleurs de ce régiment c'est de fer
et d'acier eh bien il était de fer et
d'acier maxime blasco beaucoup l'ont dit
d'ailleurs merci à tous ceux qui nous
suivent en direct sur le chat du figaro
et sur youtube de poster vos
commentaires et votre émotion
puis 12h00 - nous dit les faits d'armes
de maxime lascaux devrait être racontée
dans les écoles
vous disiez également pour certains oui
quelqu'un s'interrogeait sur la façon
dont allait se dérouler la cérémonie et
s'interrogeait sur la présence ou non
des manuels macron le chef d'état
évidemment qu emmanuel macron sera
présent il préside cette cérémonie un
hommage et on attend son arrivée il
précédera l'entrée du cercueil dans
maintenant c'est un hommage national
donc qui est dont la l'organisation est
confiée à l'état
c'est cela un hommage national
et donc il ya effectivement un certain
nombre la possibilité à chacun d'entre
nous aux français d'être présent ils
sont dans les galeries qui sont derrière
cette cour d'honneur cour d'honneur qui
est très vaste et lorsque vous marchez
dans la cour d'honneur et lorsque si
vous mettiez à parler fort il y a
un un écho qui arrive quand vous êtes
seul évidemment cette cour d'honneur
fait 104 mètres sur 62 et derrière il y
à là la cathédrale
des invalides qui a été érigé quelques
années après je crois que c'est en
1776 par l'architecte jules et hardouin
mansart
voit donc le dôme des invalides
doré à l'or fin est haut au dessus c'est
à dire au niveau du premier étage de la
première galerie il y à un buste de
napoléon qui est là depuis 1911 et qui
est très très impressionnant au réveil
est ce que vous pouvez répondre à ellan
qui s'interroge
de la présence de lionel jospin et
d'alain juppé anciennement premier
ministre pour l'un du gouvernement
chirac et l'autre c'est une tradition
d'inviter les anciens présidents de la
république et les anciens premiers
ministres l'ancien chef du gouvernement
et là vous vous l'avez dit vous-même il
ya une partie du gouvernement qui est
présent pour rendre hommage à laurence
par lee et le premier misant castex sont
à l'image en ce moment un maxime bosco
alors qu'on voyait quelques images de ce
bataillon de chasseurs alpins ont parlé
de héros il ya quelques secondes en
réveil il refusait un maxime blasco
qu'on le qualifie de héros son métier
c'était sa passion même après le crash
de la gazelle dont on a évoqué tout à
l'heure
l'histoire en 2019 malgré ses blessures
également il a failli y laisser sa vie
et sa peau malgré les tentatives de son
père pour le dissuader de retourner au
combat il a tenu à y retourner et finir
sa mission au sahel qui était maxime
blasco est ce qu on a quelques éléments
pour nous dire qui était l'homme ou en
tout cas qu'elle était voilà j'ai lu en
préparant cette émission qu'avant d'être
un soldat avant de s'engager dans
l'armée il était pâtissier oui mais vous
savez c'est un creuset l'armée c'est le
carrefour
d'engagement de gens et part de gens
divers de gens qui ont peut-être des
expériences ou qu'ils s'engagent très
très jeunes qui vont par vocation par
envie mais maxime blasco c'est le type
même du jeune homme qui a envie de faire
ce métier à travers des opérations
extérieures pour lui je présume qu'il
n'était pas question de ne pas bouger et
il a eu la chance de pouvoir intégrer un
régiment qui effectivement partie
relativement souvent dans les opérations
extérieures qui sont consommatrices
d'énergie est évidemment de force et de
soldats donc deux militaires et lui
s'étaient je ne sais si c'était sa
vocation mais c'était sa volonté c'est
là où il prenait du plaisir comme un
journaliste s'engage dans ce métier pour
aller sur le terrain pour au contact des
autres c'est exactement la même chose
al'inverse de nous et c'est un homme qui
a donné sa vie pour les autres et un
engagement je dirais beaucoup plus fort
que ne peut être celui des journalistes
en tout cas pas à placer peut-être au
même niveau qu'eux n'ont pas pas du tout
mais je jouis est-ce qu'on pressent que
du roi et d'intérêt je vis encore on va
dire
respect ou non nous dirigent galaxies
parmi les commentaires que vous laisser
sur le chat du figaro
certains s'interrogent sur la présence
de certains politiques aujourd'hui mais
nous disait henri veille c'est le
protocole c'est normal en cas de
dommages national la présence d'anciens
chefs d'état comme françois hollande qui
est là aujourd'hui et d'anciens premiers
ministres comme alain juppé ou lionel
jospin sont là aujourd'hui on a pu
également apercevoir
la ministre des armées florence parly le
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian d'autres membres du
gouvernement sont là également tous
ainsi que les militaires les familles
les proches de maxime black's blasco
sont d'ores et déjà présents dans
l'enceinte de ces invalides dans la cour
d'honneur de cet hôtel des invalides
et comme vous l'a précisé au début de ce
direct il y à quelques heures maintenant
vers 15h le cortège funéraire a traversé
le pont des invalides pour permettre à
ceux on le voit sur ces images diffusées
un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui pour
permettre à ceux qui voulaient rendre un
dernier hommage à maxime blasco et bien
devoir de pouvoir se rassembler sur ce
pont alexandre iii donc qui permet de
relier les champs elysées elle le grand
palais aux invalides l'esplanade des
invalides puis l'hôtel des invalides au
bout
peut-être est-ce la famille de maxime
blasco qu'on pourra revoir sur les
images diffusées cette fois ci en direct
de cette cour d'honneur merci de nous
laisser
de nous permettre d'écouter ou en tout
cas de lire vos commentaires et vos
questions sur les tchats du figaro et de
youtube nous sommes avec henri veille
journaliste et historien en direct pour
vous pour commenter cette décrypter
cette cérémonie en réveil vous vouliez
ajouter quelques jouets vous évoquez
tout à l'heure la compagne de maxime
blasco je crois que à l'issue de cette
cérémonie nationale elle demandera
l'autorisation au président de la
république qui seul peut la donner de
pouvoir épouser à titre posthume maxime
blasco est ce qu'il ya des raisons que
ça lui soit refusé non cette
circonstance exceptionnelle seul le
président peut donner son aval mais il
n'y a aucune raison a priori que
satisfaction ne lui soit pas donnée bien
entendu je ne vois pas pourquoi racines
internautes sur le chat du figaro nous
dit je me rappelle encore le chant loin
que chez nous résonner dans la cour des
invalides
allons-nous de nouveau l'entendre
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut répondre à cet
internaute je n'ai pas tous les éléments
de la du déroulement il ya un certain
nombre de points d'interrogation sur les
éléments dont nous disposons nous ne
sommes pas en mesure de vous répondre
par la négative ou de vous dire si oui
ou non en tout cas ce champ sera
entonnée par le choeur dans les choeurs
de l'armée nous verrons en direct ce que
nous savons en revanche c'est que le
président de la république
après avoir passé en revue les troupes
remettra sur le cercueil de maxime
blasco la croix de chevalier de la
légion d'honneur
ça fait partie du déroulé un
prévisionnel qui nous a été donnée on
assistera l'arrivée du chef de l'état
emmanuel mâcon de macron dans cette cour
d'honneur des invalides
il va être accueilli par par le premier
ministre jean castex la ministre des
armées florence parly et puis il y aura
l'honneur du drapeau président de la
république la revue des troupes du
président et puis on assistera à
l'entrée du cercueil dans la cour de
l'hôtel national des invalides et enfin
comme vous disait henri veille le
président remettra les insignes de
chevalier de la légion d'honneur au
sergent maxime blasco avant qu'on
entende la sonnerie aux morts c'est
devenu une tradition d'honorer ainsi les
militaires les militaires tués dans
l'accomplissement de leur mission on
leur remet effectivement quel que soit
leur grade
la croix de chevalier dans l'ordre
national de la légion d'honneur
maxime blasco était un soldat
expérimenté plusieurs fois décoré on l'a
dit dans quelles circonstances at il été
tué
il a été tué lors d'une opération où des
drones - drone a remarqué la présence
d'islamistes et et donc on a envoyé je
crois par hélicoptère des commandos ils
en l'occurrence des commandes de
montagne et c'est en descendant sur le
terrain il y avait un tireur embusqué
qui malheureusement a tiré une balle
dans la tête de maxime blasco c'était
vendredi celui ci a été grièvement
blessé il a été
soigner immédiatement
transportés mais lors de ce transport il
est décédé
merci de nous retrouver en direct sur
figaro l'arrivée sur la chaîne youtube
de figaro live nous allons vous faire
vivre l'hommage national
rendu à maxime blasco soldat tué au
combat par un jihadiste vendredi 24
septembre
henri veille est avec nous il est
historien il va décrypter cet hommage et
puis il va répondre à vos questions et
réagir à vos commentaires en revanche
stéphane stade il ya un commentaire que
je trouve intéressant puisque
il nous permet de repenser à ce qu'a
écrit le connaît le michel goya dans les
pages du figaro voc cette semaine
pourquoi ces héros donc c'est stéphane
stany sur le chat youtube de figaro live
pourquoi ces héros sont il mentionné
seulement une fois tombée pourquoi
faut-il attendre de tels sacrifices pour
qu'il soit honoré
voulu répondre c'est une vaste question
philosophique mais ça ramène à notre
discussion passé est ce que ces
hommes-là souhaiterait qu'ils soient
honorées vous savez pour eux lorsque
vous discutez lorsque vous les côtoyer
ils font leur métier uniquement leur
métier c'est un peu comme ces jeunes
gens qui avaient 20 ans qui en 1940 se
sont engagées immédiatement après la
défaite ne connaissons évidemment pas la
fin de l'histoire et ils se sont engagés
parce que c'était l'honneur de la france
s'est elle à rohner d'agir ainsi eh bien
les militaires il se trouve dans la même
configuration
alors que l'on voit je pense arriver
après la voiture officielle du chef de
l'état emmanuel macron escorté par les
motards
beaucoup nous parlait de l'émotion 1 qui
naît de la non sein d'un soldat français
tué
sur le terrain c'est encore une version
52e on l'a dit déjà mais on peut le
rappeler que c'est le 52e militaires
tués depuis 2000 13 pouces à l un dans
le cadre de l'opération barkan c'est
terrible ce constat faisant suite aux 90
français militaires morts en afghanistan
tomac loi qui demande sur le chat du
figaro le caporal-chef blasco a été
promu sergent à titre post mortem oui à
titre posthume c'est également habituels
ont promu au grade supérieur
le soldat qui est qui qui est décédé et
qui est mort au combat les armes à la
main
ça c'est la première séquence évidemment
cet hommage national et demain la
deuxième séquence ce seront les honneurs
militaires qui seront rendus au 7e
bataillon de chasseurs à à vars dans
l'isère une cérémonie qui sera présidée
par le chef d'état major de l'armée de
terre le général pierre schill et là on
vient de voir le président de la
république qui a salué le général
thierry burckhart chef d'état major des
armées il a salué également son premier
ministre jean castex et la ministre des
armées florence parly si la régie peut
nous mettre un peu de son en retour pour
afin qu'on entende un peu ce qui se
passe sur place ce serait formidable
[Musique]
vous souhaitez nous dire ce qu'il se
passe en ce moment après la marseillaise
évidemment
oui
m
l'hymne national a été interprétée par
la musique de la garde républicaine
et que auparavant juste avant la
marseillaise on a vu le président de la
république
trop tôt qu'alarmant quelques pas
derrière le
plus derrière le chef de l'état le
premier ministre jean castex il y avait
également le chef d'état major des
armées et le chef de l'état major
particulier du président de la
république il s'agit de l'amiral là
roland depuis l'été 2009 un
exercice de la revue des troupes ça fait
partie également du protocole donc c'est
le président qui passe en revue les
troupes présentes c'est l'opposé des
défilés militaires on va dire cette fois
ci c'est très codifié c'est très très
très codifié et effectivement ils
rendent hommage aux sections qui sont
présentes là avec
le ou les drapeaux
précisons que les troupes
de deux montagnes chaque unité n'a pas
un drapeau mais que cet homme drapeau
unique qui est transmis pour une année
un régiment là évidemment il passe en
revue
les marins
[Musique]
vous êtes nombreux à nous faire part de
votre émotion de vos témoignages et à
rendre hommage à maxime blasco sur les
tchats du figaro claudius 15 c'est la
république qui pleure l'un de ses
enfants christian léon toussaint
également qui nous dit tristesse bonjour
le peuple t'honore la gloire 30 hommage
et les choeurs versent leurs pleurs sur
toi maxime lascaux le vaillant
c'est très émouvant à ce que disent les
internautes mais vous savez il est
toujours très intéressant aussi de faire
référence à l'histoire ce régiment
auquel appartenait maxime blasco est en
régiment à 1200 hommes et femmes et il
ya un chiffre très significatif pendant
la première guerre mondiale ce régiment
a perdu 1300 militaires 1300 militaires
qui sont morts pour la france vous
imaginez
le président qui se dirige vers la
famille de maxime blasco et sa femme
alexandra qui donc devrait porter
bientôt le nom d'alexandra blasco le nom
de son mari à côté d'elle on a pu
apercevoir
et anne le fils de 8 ans maxime blasco
qui a huit ans et qui d'après ce que
nous a raconté sa maman chez nos
confrères d'rtl a prévu et à miner dans
une petite boîte certain nombre de
souvenirs qu'il a pu laisser dans le
cercueil de son papa emmanuel macron
s'entretient je crois que son papa qui
disait sur la même radio ce matin qu'il
porterait à la cravate de son fils
alors son papa justement qui disait chez
nos confrères de bfm tv que son fils
n'aurait pas aimé cet hommage national
en tout cas qu'il ne voulait pas
d'hommage national qu'il aurait préféré
probablement une une cérémonie dans
l'intimité de la famille est ce que la
famille aurait pu s'opposer à un tel
hommage ou est-ce que c'est très
difficile c'est très dur est difficile
en revanche effectivement il et les
militaires et la famille seront entre
eux demain à vars évidemment il y aura
beaucoup de monde
mais la cérémonie je dirais famille
familiale dans le sens l'armée les
militaires entre c'est demain
aujourd'hui c'est la nation dans son
entier qui rendent hommage d'un maxime
blasco dans un lieu dédié la cour
d'honneur des invalides
est ce que c'est la marche au tambour
que nous entendons pour l'entrée du
cercueil dans la cour d'honneur des
invalides en deuil
j'entends peu mais je pense que c'est
cela effectivement
on va laisser vivre quelques minutes ces
images
si c'était à l'entrée
[Musique]
par la porte qui est au fond à gauche de
l'écran
derrière ce que
cette entrée il ya celle voilà il va
passer à côté ils vont passer ce
militaire qui portent le corps de leur
camarade
devant l'entrée de la cathédrale
saint-louis des invalides
edith cresson l'ancienne première
ministre à son premier ministre sous
mitterrand est derrière
juppé
s'est prononcé également qui assistent
aux de cet hommage ce moment très
solennel très codifié très volontiers
pour tous ces militaires qui attendent
depuis un moment et qui voit arriver le
corps d'un des leurs c'est très
oh
à la hauteur de ces enjeux
de la même façon vous voyez les dits
porteurs du cercueil
ce doit être un moment extrêmement
triste pour eux parce que là
la majorité où tous connaissez ce
camarade c'était ses frères d'armes les
frères de maxime blasco c'est vraiment
cette terminologie est parfaitement
adapté à la situation mon frère d'armé
mans
j'admire les parents parce que vous
évoquez ce matin l'interview et la
dignité d'un père la dignité d'une
compagne face à la mort d'
du combattant opposé héroïque que nous
nous disions nous le reverrons plus mon
nous avons cette image et nous savons en
parler dignement
[Musique]
drapeaux des chasseurs sans votre garde
rejoignez votre complètement
ce matin le colonel lecalvez qui est qui
est le chef de corps de de ce régiment
disait la mission continue
c'est le plus bel hommage que l'on peut
lui rendre
emmanuel macron devrait maintenant
remettre les insignes de chevalier de la
légion d'honneur au sergent maxime
blasco
le cercueil recouvert d'un drapeau
présenté à mais en principe réservé le
drapeau tricolore présent sur un
cercueil aux militaires ou anciens
militaires vous voyez le bonbon
[Musique]
la légion d'honneur a remises en
principe pour des mérites éminents
du vivant de quelqu'un et là évidemment
ses mérites sont évidents
sergent maxime blasco
au nom de la république française
nous vous faisons officier de la légion
d'honneur
alors c'est tout à fait exceptionnel
parce que effectivement généralement on
lui remet la croix de chevalier et l'a
directement ce qui est prévu par le code
de la légion de m
maxime blasco est fait officier de la
légion d'honneur c'est vraiment une
reconnaissance exceptionnelle de la
nation à travers le geste du président
de la république
c'est un choix qui revient aux
présidents des allemands c'est le grand
maître de l'ordre et la légion d'honneur
et de l'ordre national du mérite
[Musique]
posés au
dans la légion d'honneur il il ya trois
grades et de dignité et là effectivement
comme nous venons de le dire
le sergent maxime blasco a été
directement promu officier de la légion
d'honneur
c'est très émouvant toujours les
internautes aussi font part de leur
émotion de leurs larmes
ça tient aux coûts des films
[Musique]
présentés aux
comores alors aux morts c'est apparu
au cours de la première guerre mondiale
le tambour est très important dans ce
type de cérémonie on l'avait vu et
rythme on a serré
[Musique]
mais de silence
m
[Musique]
et a priori maintenant le le cercueil va
sortir de la cour d'honneur des
invalides
alors qu'on vient d'entendre mars par la
musique de la garde républicaine
le président s'est recueilli devant le
cercueil devant la dépouille de maxime
blasco
même temps les dits porteurs devraient
revenir drapeaux des chasseurs rejoignez
votre gardien
chef de l'état qui ne devrait pas
prononcé de discours
les engins déroulé prévisionnel
je crois que c'est la famille qui ne
tenant pas un hommage national de
l'ampleur
et puis je crois que emmanuel macron ne
peut pas faire de discours à tous tous
les soldats morts au combat
repos
[Musique]
présenter
il ya une première information c'est
beaucoup de monde est présent
côté officiel évidemment mais également
dans les galeries au premier étage
lorsqu'on regarde
précisément on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de
monde qui est venu rendre hommage à ce
soldat et c'est vrai que c'est je sais
je ne dirais pas que c'est inhabituel
il ya quelque chose de par le profil qui
a meurtri des français et qu'ils le
manifestent la et un deuxième élément
aussi c'est le fait que vous le
soulignez il n'y a pas de prise de
parole alors que logiquement il ya un
éloge qui peut être effectuée par le
chef de l'état il aurait parfaitement pu
le faire mais je crois que
ça renforce
l'immense moment de recueillement
extrêmement court mais que vous nous
venons de vivre et qui a rajouté à la
solennité de ce moment
les français sont toujours en réveil
très touchée systématiquement d'aquin un
soldat meurt au combat parce qu'on si on
dévoile aussi la personnalité du soldat
qui a été tout est situé son engagement
son profil
oui la famille aussi la famille qu'il
laisse derrière lui et la maxime de
lascaux laisse une femme et un enfant
dont
le père de famille qui se projette pas
qu'elle est la mère de famille ne se
projette pas ça pour être m'en fous je
connais
des familles dans le fils ou une fille
c'est un jeu
expression
cette proximité c'est pas mal
oui
émotion effectivement parce qu'il ya
cette projection qui intervient
regardez ce parc à rien dauphin on
détecte
sur les visages des gens
sur la marche funèbre de chopin on va
l'écouter
de ce moment là
il
oui
non
[Musique]
oui
et
e
non
[Musique]
repos
en réveil
vous qui êtes historien
mais journaliste également qu'elle quel
regard vous portez sur une cérémonie
comme celle qu'on vient de vivre elle
m'a beaucoup ému j'ai assisté à pas mal
de cérémonie pour notamment la mort de
deux militaires
je suis particulièrement ému aujourd'hui
parce que
la lumière d'un peu de ce que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure ce que j'ai ressenti
cette immense fraternité d'armes qui
n'est pas un vain mot qui est une
réalité parce que chacun de ces hommes
là que l'on voit que quel que soit leur
âge quelle que soit leur parcours et sur
leurs grades
ressent au plus profond de lui-même la
douleur de perdre un compagnon un
camarade
un militaire comme lui et je crois que
la nation aussi quels que soient son
rapport à l'armée quel que soit le
sentiment qui peut avoir pour
l'institution ne peut également que 4
ému par ce qu'il a vu et puis je vous
dis je crois que le profil l'engagement
de maxime blasco joue beaucoup c'est à
dire qu'on a beaucoup raconté où on a
logiquement raconter son histoire ce
qu'il avait fait notamment en 2019 et
qu'il y avait valu le 18 juin sur ce au
même endroit d'être décoré par le
président de la république il ya deux
prise d'armé
annuel par le président de la république
cet endroit précis et vous vous rendez
compte le 18 juin dernier le président
avait lui avais agrafé
la médaille militaire
sur maxime blasco et il doit se dire le
président
quelques semaines plus tard je reviens
c'est pour lui dire adieu c'est terrible
effectivement
alors que la cérémonie d'hommage
national à maxime l'aspo blasco s'achève
qu il ajouté
puis reviennent toujours des notions qui
sont pas assez enseigné de patrie c'est
cette notion d'engagement qui revient
elle aussi souvent dans le discours
public mais l'engagement jusqu'où
l'engagement pourquoi et là on a un
certain nombre de réponses qui sont
fournis à travers l'histoire de cet
homme qui a donné sa vie pour remplir la
mission
je cite quelques uns de vos commentaires
à vous qui nous suivaient sur sur
lefigaro.fr et sur youtube et galaxy
nous dit par exemple cérémonie émouvante
sobre et simple à l'image de ce héros
même s'il n'aurait pas aimé être
désignés ainsi il en est un sans
conteste et c'est un peu ce qu'on se
disait tout à l'heure tu ce que nous
disons ça c'est vraiment une marque de
fabrique du militaire c'est que n'ont
ils pas un héros il fait son travail et
comme le disait le chef de corps du
régiment de maxime blasco ce matin au
micro d'une radio et bien la mort
malheureusement ça c'est moi qui rajoute
malheureusement fait partie du métier
c'est une hypothèse de travail lorsqu'on
signe son contrat
mais là la mission continue disait aussi
ce chef de corps et est aujourd'hui
encore bien entendu il y a une
cinquantaine de chasseurs alpins qui
sont au mali
et que d'autres leur succéderont
pour remplir la mission
proposée au
repos
présenté
à disposition du comité interne
j'ai évoqué le comportement de chasseurs
alpins pendant la première guerre
mondiale une anecdote
les chasseurs alpins ont fait sidi
brahim qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que l'on fait référence à une
bataille qui a opposé au 19e siècle les
troupes françaises à celle de l'émir
abdelkader et que n'ayant plus de
munitions ils ont continué à se battre
avec des pierres et donc c'est ce qui
montre la vaillance des combattants tout
simplement et que autres temps autres
moeurs mais je pense qu'une
caractéristique est en lien qui relie un
siècle après les hommes c'est le courage
et la vaillance lorsqu il en faut pour
faire ce métier dans les conditions dans
lesquelles
on est engagé et même si la peur est une
compagnie régulière
que l'on voit les membres du
gouvernement qui étaient là la cour
d'honneur des invalides
je lis quelques uns de vos témoignages
vos commentaires alise rannou dit sur le
chat futur vegard alive c'est grâce à
ces hommes de l'ombre que nous vivons
sereinement c'est grâce à leurs
sacrifices au quotidien est parfois de
leur vie merci à eux merci à toi maxime
repose en paix ineas nous précise quant
à elle beaucoup d'émotion j'ai des
frissons et des larmes aux yeux on ne se
résume ça résume parfaitement je crois
ce que nous venons de vivre et je crois
que ce que dit cet internaute chacun
d'entre nous si nous sommes devant notre
écran de télévision ou ceux qui sont
présents quelle que soit leur fonction
et un présent à l'hôtel national des
invalides a pu le ressentir je crois que
c'est impossible ou ne pas se trouver
dans cet état d'esprit avec
effectivement les larmes qui perlent aux
yeux
je crois au réveil que nous arrivons au
terme ce direct je vous remercie
beaucoup on était avec nous cet
après-midi pour commenter cet hommage
national à maxime blasco il avait 34 ans
il a été tué par un djihadiste au mali
pendant un combat sur le terrain
emmanuel m'a compris et bacon présidait
cette cérémonie aux invalides
vous avez pu la vivre avec nous on
rappelle aussi que maxime blasco et le
52e militaire français décédé en
opération au sel depuis le lancement de
l'opération barkan en 2013
henri veille je vous remercie encore
vous êtes je le rappelle journaliste et
historien puis je vais rappeler le titre
de votre dernier ouvrage résister à 20
ans l'engagement des compagnons la
libération c'est édité chez privat et
pour ceux qui veulent en savoir plus sur
maxime blasco bas je vous encourage à
lire la tribune émouvante qui lui a
consacré le colonel michel goya dans les
pages figaro vox le fun 6 septembre
dernier le caporal chef maxime blasko un
exemple de courage et d'humilité à très
vite sur figaro live